[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen allen eigentlich wäre heute
kein Wahlabend wenn Berlin die reguläre
Wahl zu seinem Landesparlament so
korrekt hinbekommen hätte wie man es in
einer Demokratie erwarten muss Berlin
hat das bekanntlich nicht geschafft und
so gucken wir hier gleich auf
Hochrechnungen so guckt Deutschland auf
seine Hauptstadt die immer noch viel
liebenswertes hat aber in der
überforderte Verwaltung und offenbar
strukturelle Verantwortungslosigkeit
dazu führten das sogar eine Wahl
wiederholt werden muss eine Wiederholung
bei der die CDU zum ersten Mal seit zwei
Jahrzehnten stärkste Partei wurde und
die SPD ihr schlechtestes Berliner
Ergebnis seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik einfuhr
matthias vornhof hat den aktuellen Stand
der Hochrechnungen für uns live aus
Berlin guten Abend Matthias guten Abend
90 Prozent der Stimmen sind ausgezählt
und wir schauen auf die frischesten
Zahlen sprich die neue Hochrechnung
demnach bekommt die SPD 18,4 Prozent und
verliert drei Punkte die CDU 28,1
Prozent mehr als 10 Punkte dazu gewonnen
die Grünen 18,5 mit leichten Verlusten
die Linke 12,3 mit Verlusten die AFD
9,01 mehr die FDP 4,7 Verluste und damit
nicht im Abgeordnetenhaus vertreten und
wir schauen jetzt was das heißt für die
Koalitionsmöglichkeiten Christian ja
gerne macht das euch gleich weiter
Matthias okay oder sehen wir bei
insgesamt 154 sitzen also das
Abgeordnetenhaus wird etwas größer
werden durch Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate braucht man 78 da
liegt die absolute Mehrheit SPD
Bündnis was bisher hier reagiert hat
kommt auf 88 das reicht also dicke CDU
und SPD kämen auf
83 auch das deutlich drüber und die CDU
mit den Grünen ebenfalls auf 83 es gibt
also diverse Möglichkeiten hier eine
Regierung zu bilden wir sprechen uns ich
habe es gerade vorhin gesagt ja heute
Abend nur deshalb weil die letzte Wahl
nicht korrekt lief wie war es denn
diesmal nach unserer Reporterinnen und
Reporter waren vor Ort in den
Wahllokalen wo es besonders schief
gelaufen war und haben berichtet dass es
diesmal alles gesittet gut organisiert
war 4000 Wahlhelferinnen und Helfer mehr
das hat offensichtlich gut funktioniert
so sieht es auch der Landeswahlleiter
alles sei glatt gelaufen und damit haben
wir wissen eine gute Nachricht heute
schon mal ganz sicher dass nämlich
Berlin noch wählen kann wenn auch erst
im zweiten Anlauf Matthias Vorlauf
herzlichen Dank Berlin ist arm aber sexy
den Spruch hatte mal Klausur bereit
geprägt mittlerweile wirkt Berlin immer
noch arm aber immer häufiger nicht mehr
sexy und dennoch lässt diese Stadt viele
Menschen die sie mal wirklich
kennengelernt haben nie wieder los eine
Stadt in der
nicht viel geht aber alles möglich ist
das zum ersten Mal wegen Pannen eine
Wahl in einem Bundesland wiederholt
werden muss so gesehen war klar dass
konnte nur in Berlin passieren ein
besonderer Wahltag in der Hauptstadt und
sein Ergebnis zusammengefasst von Markus
groß und romaneskova
Jubel Applaus siegesstimmung Kai Wegner
oben auf 10% Punkte dazu gewonnen für
die in den letzten Jahren nicht gerade
erfolgsverwöhnte CDU ein sensationelles
Ergebnis
es ist phänomenal
und ich kann nur sagen
Berlin hat den Wechsel gewählt
kurz nach 18 Uhr bei der SPD lange
Gesichter die Zahlen niederschmetternd
ein bitterer Abend für die Amtsinhaberin
Franziska Giffey und ihre Partei es ist
schon
für die SPD natürlich
hier eine Abstimmung getroffen wurde
über diese Koalition als Ganzes und egal
wie es weitergeht es muss wirklich
gravierende Veränderungen geben klare
Worte aber ganz geschlagen geben will
sie sich eine halbe Stunde später doch
nicht wenn wir eine Möglichkeit haben
ein Regierungsbündnis einzuführen unter
SPD-Führung dann werden wir auch
versuchen dafür eine stabile politische
Mehrheit zu organisieren die Grünen
dürften da genau zugehört haben
Spitzenkandidatin Jara schliefert sich
bis zur Stunde ein Duell mit der SPD um
Platz 2 die Absichten der Grünen
scheinen klar aber mit deutlich anderem
Akzent als bei den Sozialdemokraten wir
werden natürlich
gesprächseinladungen annehmen und mit
demokratischen Parteien reden sowieso
wir haben aber auch von Anfang an und
zwar sehr klar gesagt dass wir eine
Präferenz haben wir würden gerne die
Koalition mit der SPD und den linken
fortführen am liebsten unter grüne
Führung
welche Parteien auch immer künftig im
Roten Rathaus regieren stehen vor einem
riesigen Berg von Problemen Frust bei
vielen Berlinern die pannenwahl 2021 hat
die verwaltungsdefizite schonungslos
offengelegt dazu der schleppende
Wohnungsbau steigende Mieten ein
enteignungsentscheid der auf eine
Entscheidung wartet
die Linken werden das zur Bedingung
einer neuen Koalition machen sie sind
mit dem Wahlergebnis zufrieden trotz
leichter Verluste die afd-anhänger
applaudieren die Rechtspopulisten
gewinnen dazu sind aber wohl nichts
zweistellig
Zitterpartie bei der FDP stand jetzt
sind sie wohl raus aus dem Parlament
kein Wegner genießt den Rom an diesem
Abend sieht einen klaren
Regierungsauftrag für die Stadt eine
Mission wir werden hart daran arbeiten
dass Berlin tagtäglich ein bisschen
besser funktioniert aber wird eher nur
ein Held für einen Tag auch Rot-Grün-Rot
oder grün rot rot ist möglich es bleibt
spannend in Berlin
ja seit mehr als 20 Jahren hatte die CDU
in der Stadt nichts mehr zu sagen jetzt
liegt sie vorn und zwar sehr deutlich
weil Wegener ist der CDU Spitzenkandidat
und jetzt live bei uns Herr Wegner guten
Abend
schönen guten Abend jetzt hört man aber
auch schon sie hätten sich tot gesiegt
ein Sieger ohne Freunde lässt sich so
ihre Lage beschreiben heute Abend
na erstmal freue ich mich dass die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner ein Wechsel
gewählt haben die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner haben uns mir das Vertrauen
gegeben und wir haben jetzt den Auftrag
eine stabile Regierung für zu bilden und
dazu werden wir in den nächsten Tagen
Gespräche führen wir werden andere
Parteien einladen und noch mal mein Ziel
ist eine stabile Regierung eine
verlässliche Regierung die
zusammenarbeitet und eine Regierung die
die Probleme endlich anpackt und nicht
länger liegen lässt was wollen Sie denn
SPD oder grünen anbieten damit die zu
ihnen wechseln und nicht weitermachen
mit der bisherigen Koalition
ich glaube heute ist nicht der Tag wo es
um Angebote geht sondern wir müssen
natürlich Angebote machen weil wenn sie
keine Angebote machen dann sind sie ein
Wahlsieger der am Ende nichts draus
machen kann aber wissen Sie heute haben
doch die Berlinerinnen und Berliner
gesprochen und jetzt glaube ich müssen
erstmal alle Parteien dieses Ergebnis
auch zur Kenntnis nehmen es gibt massive
Verschiebungen alle drei
Regierungsparteien haben verloren wir
sind deutlich gewachsen und wir haben
den Auftrag jetzt eine Regierung zu
bilden und das werden wir dann in
Gesprächen mit den Grünen aber auch mit
der SPD gemeinsam besprechen mit wem
geht es denn aus ihrer Sicht einfacher
jetzt ist ja so ihre Lage dass die SPD
in Berlin tendenziellen linker ist und
die Grünen grüner als anderswo was
glauben Sie mit wem wird es einfacher
das werden die Gespräche zeigen dass
alles Entscheidende ist dass wir
aufhören mit dem Streit wissen Sie was
die Berlinerinnen und Berliner glaube
ich mit der meisten genervt hat ist das
in den sechs Jahren Rot-Grün-Rot immer
gestritten wurde und zwar auf offener
Bühne und natürlich sind das
unterschiedliche Parteien die
Koalitionen bilden und es wird auch
Diskussionen geben es wird vielleicht
doch mal Streit geben aber der Streit
muss nach innen geführt werden und nach
außen muss eine Regierung gemeinsam
arbeiten und Berlin ein Stück weit
besser zu machen dafür zu sorgen dass
diese Stadt funktioniert und das ist
mein Anspruch und das werden wir in den
Sondierungen mit den anderen Parteien
besprechen
sie sind aber nicht erst seit gestern in
der Landespolitik sie werden sich ja
schon Gedanken darüber gemacht haben mit
wem es einfacher geht deswegen frage ich
das noch mal
es gibt Unterschiede zu den Parteien das
ist doch gar keine Frage die sind ja
auch im Wahlkampf jetzt sehr deutlich
geworden gerade in der Verkehrspolitik
mit den Grünen zum Beispiel so aber das
muss man jetzt in den Sondierungen
besprechen ich habe da wirklich keine
Präferenz wir laden Ergebnis auf dem ein
und werden mit der SPD und mit den
Grünen sprechen wie gut können denn ihre
CDU mit dieser aktuellen Lage jetzt
umgehen ihr Generalsekretär hatte vor
einem wahlklau ich zitiere ihn gewarnt
jetzt ist ja so wer eine Mehrheit als
Koalition zusammen bekommen das nennt
sich Demokratie und nicht wahlklau auch
wenn am Ende die CDU dann nicht mit
dabei ist
aber Demokratie ist auch immer den
Wähler Willen zu respektieren und der
Wähler Wille ist sehr eindeutig wer
jetzt eine Regierung anführen soll wer
den Auftrag zur Bildung einer Regierung
hat und darum geht es jetzt wissen sie
der Wahlkampf ist jetzt vorbei wir
hatten einen harten Wahlkampf wo
Unterschiede deutlich wo inzwischen den
Parteien aber jetzt ist nicht mehr
Wahlkampf jetzt geht es um Verantwortung
für Berlin es geht um eine erfolgreiche
berlin-koalition die will ich anführen
und die will ich jetzt erstmal zustande
bringen wie oft fragen sie sich Mensch
ich hätte vielleicht doch noch was
anderes machen müssen in diesem
Wahlkampf um ein Ergebnis einzufahren
das am Ende an mir keiner wirklich
vorbeikommt denn das Ergebnis haben sie
ja heute Abend nicht
wissen Sie ich glaube kaum einer hat
damit gerechnet dass die Berliner CDU so
abschneidet wie wir heute abgeschnitten
haben und ich danke den Berlinerinnen
und Berliner für den Vertrauensvorschuss
und ich will jetzt die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner überzeugen dass es ein
Vertrauensbeweis war das ist meine
Aufgabe in den nächsten dreieinhalb
Jahren und dafür will ich hart arbeiten
dürfte was würden Sie darauf wetten dass
es bald Regierender Bürgermeister Kai
Wegner heißt
schauen wir mal eine ganze Menge eine
ganze Menge heißt was
wollen Sie jetzt eine konkrete Summe von
mir wissen oder ein Bier oder irgend
sowas das Entscheidende ist doch dass
wir jetzt vertrauensvoll mit dem
Ergebnis der Berlinerinnen und Berliner
umgehen müssen es geht um Vertrauen und
es geht um diese Stadt das geht nicht um
mich es geht und nicht um Parteien
sondern es geht darum dass Politik
wieder Vertrauen gewinnt und dass die
Berliner das Gefühl haben Ihr Arbeiten
Leute zusammen die wirklich was tun
damit sie den Berlinern besser geht sagt
der Wahlsieger kein Wegner von der CDU
Herr Wegener vielen Dank nach Berlin
danke Ihnen
und dann machen wir gleich weiter in
Berlin mit Franziska Giffey SPD sie ist
die bisherige Regierende Bürgermeisterin
von Berlin vorgefallen guten Abend auch
an sie
schönen guten Abend wie groß ist der
noch ihre Chance dass sie auch die
künftige Regierende Bürgermeisterin sind
naja es kommt drauf an wir warten ja
jetzt auf das Ergebnis für Platz 2 wir
sind im Moment seit mehreren Stunden
gleich auf mit der mit den Grünen und
für uns ist entscheidend dass wir auf
Platz zwei kommen und dann gibt es eben
die Möglichkeit ein Bündnis zu schmieden
wie es auch bisher
seine Arbeit gemacht hat mit den Grünen
und den linken und für uns ist natürlich
die erste Wunsch Option die die
ermöglicht dass die SPD weiterführende
Kraft im Roten Rathaus in dieser
Landesregierung ist und das ist auch für
uns der erste sondierungspunkt jetzt
haben sie allerdings heute Abend auch
schon mehrfach gesagt dass Wahlergebnis
zeigt ganz klar dass die Menschen
Veränderung wollen ich zitiere sie
wörtlich es kann nicht so weitergehen
wie bisher sprechen Sie da auch über
sich selbst
also wissen sie erst einmal müssen wir
klar sehen die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner haben hier ein deutliches Votum
abgegeben und das ist absolut ernst zu
nehmen es gibt eine Unzufriedenheit mit
natürlich auch einer Gesamtsituation wir
haben eine Wahlwiederholung das ist ein
sehr seltener Vorgang und auch die
krisenhaften lagen im letzten Jahr sind
natürlich auch schwer zu tragen ich habe
trotzdem
diesen Senat in diesen 13 Monaten so
geführt dass Berlin gut durch die Krise
gekommen ist dass wir auch gestärkt aus
dieser Krise hervorgehen mit einem
überdurchschnittlichen
Wirtschaftswachstum wir haben die
Berliner und Berliner entlastet und wir
haben eine erfolgreiche Arbeit gemacht
und jetzt die Frage wie ist heute
anschauen erfolgreiche Arbeit sagen Sie
jetzt wollen sie das tatsächlich als
Vertrauensbeweis deuten sie haben sogar
ihren eigenen Wahlkreis verloren
also zunächst einmal ist ganz klar wir
müssen uns sehr genau anschauen warum
haben die Berlin und Berliner so
entschieden es gibt offensichtlich eine
Unzufriedenheit deshalb habe ich auch
gesagt wir müssen Dinge auch verändern
so wie es ist kann es eben nicht bleiben
selbst wenn wir in der bisherigen
Koalition Arbeiten es braucht
Veränderung es braucht eine
Neuaufstellung das Ergebnis ist heute
hier sehr bitter für die SPD das muss
man ganz klar sagen und deshalb ist
logisch dass wir nicht einfach so
weitermachen können selbst wenn wir die
politische Mehrheit dafür bekommen und
das auch möglich ist kann man natürlich
sagen das braucht Veränderung sagen sie
warum sie das erst jetzt merken sie sind
ja bereits die Amts Inhaberin es gibt
diese interessante Geschichte von ihrem
Vorgänger Michael Müller dem fiel erst
auch wie schmutzig ist in der Stadt
Berlin ist als er nicht mehr im Amt war
als er nicht mehr mit seinem Dienstwagen
durch die Stadt gefahren wurde sie sind
deutlich mehr unterwegs gewesen als
Michael Müller am Zustand der Stadt
scheint es aber nicht viel geändert zu
haben worauf würden sie das konkret
zurückführen dass so abgeschnitten haben
wie sie abgeschnitten haben
13 Monate Zeit gehabt ich bin sehr sehr
viel in der Stadt unterwegs ich habe 16
Jahre in Neukölln im Brennpunkt
gearbeitet ich kenne die Lage in der
Stadt nur sie können in 13 Monaten eben
nicht alles verändern und erreichen was
sie sich für fünf Jahre vorgenommen
haben und deswegen ist es ganz klar es
geht um das Thema Verkehr es geht um das
Thema Wohnungsbau und es geht auch um
die innere Sicherheit in der Stadt und
wir brauchen eine sehr große Klarheit
beim Thema innere Sicherheit das war
sehr entscheidend für viele Menschen die
sich mehr Sicherheit wünschen und da
müssen wir eben noch mehr als bisher
unsere Polizei Stärken klar sein beim
Thema innere Sicherheit und das muss man
auch besprechen mit den
Koalitionspartnern wie auch immer dann
die die Konstellation aussehen kann
jetzt geht es erstmal darum dass wir
klären müssen und ich hoffe das klärt
sich in den nächsten Minuten und Stunden
ob wir auf Platz zwei sind und welche
Möglichkeiten wir dann haben und das
werden wir in den Gremien der SPD auch
besprechen auch was anders gemacht
werden muss in der Zukunft unter dem
Eindruck auch dieses Ergebnisses möchten
Sie lieber die Nummer 2 sein hinter dem
CDU-Mann Kai Wegner den wir hier gerade
in der Sendung hatten oder lieber hinter
der Grünen yarasch am Ende in einer
Dreierkoalition was wäre denn da ihre
Idee jetzt ihre Strategie
also zunächst mal glaube ich geht es
darum für Berlin den besten Weg zu
finden und das bedeutet wir müssen über
Themen sprechen wir müssen darüber reden
wo die handelnden Akteure mit der Stadt
hin wollen wo auch Kompromissfähigkeit
da ist weil wesentlichen Fragen und dann
wird zu klären sein was der beste Weg
für diese Stadt ist ich hoffe nach wie
vor dass die SPD auf Platz zwei kommt
dann haben wir die Möglichkeit
Unterführung der SPD ein Bündnis mit den
Grünen und den Linken zu schmieden um
auch weiter den Führungsanspruch hier in
der Stadt auch zu behaupten ich nehme
dem also dass das ihre erste Priorität
ist weiterzumachen wie bisher mit
derselben Koalition
es ist unsere erste Priorität ein
Bündnis zu schmieden unter dem die SPD
die Führung hat wir werden natürlich
nicht einfach so weitermachen können
auch in so einem Bündnis es muss über
inhaltliche Gespräche dann auch dazu
kommen dass wir Veränderungen dort
machen wo die Menschen jetzt
Unzufriedenheit gezeigt haben ganz kurz
noch Frau Giffey was sagen sie zu ihrem
Vorgänger Michael Müller der heute kurz
nach Schließung der Wahllokale bei den
Kollegen der ARD sagte jetzt brauche es
einen selbstkritischen Umgang in der
eigenen Partei der SPD nach solchen
Wahlen
also wissen Sie Michael Müller waren
Verantwortung als entschieden wurde über
den die Umsetzung der Wahl die Fehler
die bei der letzten Wahl passiert sind
sind nicht in meiner Amtszeit passiert
und ich finde wir sollten alle gut
miteinander umgehen was die Frage angeht
wie wir jetzt weitermachen aber man muss
schon sehen wer für welchen Teil der
Geschichte Verantwortung trägt und da
hat mich ja im Müller auch einen Anteil
daran wie die letzten Wahlen gelaufen
sind er war nämlich zu der Zeit
handelnder Regierender Bürgermeister
sagt Franziska Giffey aktuell noch die
handelnde Regierende Bürgermeisterin von
Berlin vorgefert ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich für das Gespräch
ja sehr gerne
die Berliner Wahl Wiederholung dazu
jetzt der Kommentar von
zdf-chefredakteurin Bettina Schausten
na also geht doch Berlin hat gewählt und
sogar unfallfrei was eine
Selbstverständlichkeit sein müsste
schafft die deutsche Hauptstadt erst im
Wiederholungsfall immerhin man muss
Berlin alles zutrauen sogar dass es eine
Wahl organisiert bekommt aber die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner sind es leid
Chaos bei Verwaltung und Verkehr zu
wenig Wohnungen silvesterkrawalle all
das hat der CDU die Welle zugetrieben
ihr Spitzenkandidat Kai Wegner schafft
nach mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten einen
historischen Erfolg von der Berliner
Wechselstimmung wurde rot grün rot vor
allem die SPD kalt erwischt eine
persönliche Niederlage auch für die
regierende Franziska Giffey der ist in
anderthalb Jahren nicht gelang genügend
Vertrauen aufzubauen das jetzt getragen
hätte ihr wir haben verstanden kommt
heute zu spät
ja die rot-grün-rote Mehrheit ist da und
darauf hinzuweisen dass auch der
kleinere Partner den Chef stellen kann
ist legitim und nicht unanständig wie es
heute aus der CDU hieß doch richtig ist
dieser Berliner Paukenschlag ist
unüberhörbar und dazu müssen sich jetzt
vor allem die Grünen Verhalten eine
Regierende Bürgermeisterin jarasch mit
einer gedemütigten SPD an der Seite
schwer vorstellbar dafür liegt was
bisher undenkbar erschien jetzt in der
Berliner Luft Schwarz-Grün
Berlin hat gewählt alles andere als nur
eine Wiederholungswahl egal wie es
ausgeht die Aufgabe ist klar es braucht
neue Ideen für eine großartige Stadt in
der zu wenige Menschen an eine gute
Zukunft glauben
Bettina Schausten kommentierte und dann
gucken wir jetzt auf das was heute auch
noch wichtig war Hanna du hast die
Übersicht ja blicken wir zuerst auf die
Lage in der Ukraine genauer auf die
Situation rund um bachmut im Osten des
Landes die russische Söldnergruppe
Wagner erklärte heute einen Vorort der
schwer umkämpften Stadt eingenommen zu
haben von ukrainischer Seite hieß es
zuvor das bachmut selbst weiterhin von
der Ukraine gehalten werde und man
versuche die Frontlinie um die Stadt
herum zu stabilisieren seit Monaten
liefern sich Russland und die Ukraine
heftige Kämpfe um bachmut und melden
hohe Verluste auf beiden Seiten
bundesinnenministerin ferser hat sich
für eine bessere Verteilung der
ukrainischen geflüchteten innerhalb
Europas ausgesprochen sollte es eine
weitere große Fluchtbewegung aus der
Ukraine geben müssten besonders die
osteuropäischen Nachbarn entlastet
werden sagte ferser in der Bild am
Sonntag Polen habe bislang über 1,5
Millionen ukrainische Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen Spanien 160.000 das können
nicht so bleiben erklärte Fässer
zypern hat einen neuen Präsidenten
gewählt und zwar den früheren
Außenminister Nikos christrodulides der
Mitte Rechtspolitiker kam auf 51,9% der
Stimmen in einer Stichwahl hat er sich
gegen den Diplomaten Andreas
durchgesetzt als Präsident und
Regierungschef steht festoolides vor
Herausforderungen einer Wirtschaftskrise
und dem innenpolitischen Dauerthema die
seit 2017 festgefahrenen Gespräche zur
Wiedervereinigung mit dem Norden der
Insel
die Zahlen sind nicht mehr wirklich
fassbar 35.000 tote jetzt bereits im
Erdbebengebiet in der Türkei und Syrien
die UNO rechnet mit 50.000 Toten und
mehr
wir müssen uns immer wieder klar machen
hinter diesen nüchternen Zahlen stecken
Mütter die um ihre Kinder weinen Kinder
die ihre Eltern verloren haben Verwandte
die in Trümmer Berge hineinrufen in der
Hoffnung dass ihnen noch jemand
antwortet und dann mit der
niederschmetternden Stille leben müssen
es gibt noch Wunder auch heute wurden
Menschen Lebens gerettet darunter ein
sieben Monate altes Baby aber vor allem
gibt es leid grenzüberschreitend
Mahmut Abdel chiheld und seine Familie
hatten Glück sie überlebten als ihr
vierstöckiges Haus im Nordwesten Syriens
einstürzte sie schafften es gerade noch
rechtzeitig nach draußen
die meisten meiner Hausnachbarn sind tot
wir haben im ersten Stock gewohnt als
ich auf der Treppe war stürzte eine Wand
ein eine Säule am Eingang verfehlte mich
nur knapp wir haben nur durch ein Wunder
überlebt
hunderte Tote gab es hier in gendaris
doch auf Hilfe warten die Menschen
vergebens sie fühlen sich von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft vergessen
und sie haben Recht meinte heute der
un-nothilfe-koordinator Griffith wir
haben die Menschen im Nordwesten Syriens
bisher im Stich gelassen schrieb er oft
Twitter Hilfe kommt aber oft nur durch
wenn Syriens macht aber Assad ist
zulässt so wollte ein Konvoy des
kurdischen Roten Halbmonds Hilfsgüter
nach Aleppo bringen wurde aber von der
syrischen Regierung gestoppt die
verlangt Wege Zoll bekommen keine
Genehmigung weiter zu fahren in das
Gebiet um dort Hilfe zu leisten es sei
denn wir geben mindestens die Hälfte
unserer gesamten Hilfsgüter ab auf der
anderen Seite der Grenze in der Türkei
kommen dagegen seit Tagen
Hilfslieferungen an warum ist Essen für
die die obdachlos geworden sind die
jetzt zumindest ein Zeltdach über dem
Kopf haben
knapp eine Woche ist es nun her als die
Katastrophe auch über die Stadt caraman
Marash hereinbrach eigentlich kann es
nach dieser langen Zeit ein solches Bild
nicht geben und doch ist es wahr einen
26-jährigen Mann bergen sie aus dem
Trümmerhaufen seines Hauses Gott sei
Dank Gottes größer rufen Sie und der
Gerettete hat die Kraft sein zweites
Leben mit zu feiern dass ihm heute
geschenkt wurde über 140 Stunden nach
dem Beten
und auch das ist zu vermelden dass die
Staatsmacht Schuldige sucht für die
vermuteten Baumängel die die Häuser in
sich zusammenfallen ließen so wird am
Istanbuler Flughafen ein Bauunternehmer
festgenommen der sich offenbar absetzen
wollte
wir haben die Büros für Erdbeben
Kriminalität eingerichtet alle
oberstaatsanwälte in den zehn
betroffenen Provinzen arbeiten auf
Hochtouren und sie haben bereits mit
ihren Ermittlungen begonnen
und zum Schluss die Hoffnung auf
Annäherung zwischen zweien die sich
gerade noch Spinne Feind waren Besuch
des griechischen Außenministers sein
türkischer Amtskollege begrüßt ihn als
Freund Dank für die Hilfe und sagt man
wolle wieder miteinander reden
die Bundesregierung will ein
unbürokratisches visa-verfahren für
Betroffene des Erdbebens möglich machen
damit sie zeitweilig bei
Familienangehörigen in Deutschland
unterkommen können
und jetzt hier bei uns Hannah du mit
ganz viel Sport ja und da beginnen wir
mit der Fußball-Bundesliga da gab es
heute zwei Begegnungen Hertha BSC traf
auf Borussia Mönchengladbach und siegte
mit vier zu eins und außerdem empfing
der erste fC Köln Eintracht Frankfurt
entstand drei zu null
die deutsche Biathletin die dies Hermann
Wick hat heute bei der WM in Oberhof
eine Silbermedaille in der Verfolgung
erkennt zwei Tage nach dem WM Gold im
Sprint war für die sechs in lange Zeit
im Rennen ein weiterer Sieg möglich doch
viel viel Schüsse bedeuteten am Ende
silber gold gegen an die Französin Julia
Simon Bronze an Martha olsbürste Land
aus Norwegen
Francesco Friedrich hat heute den
Gesamtweltcup im Viererbob gewonnen im
letzten Saison Rennen in Innsbruck
gelang Friedrich sein 73 Star Weltcup
Sieg im Bahn Rekord er verwies seinen
schärfsten Konkurrenten den dritten Brad
Hall of Rang 2 dieser landete auch im
Gesamtweltcup auf dem zweiten Platz
gefolgt von dem deutschen Johannes
Lochner auf Rang 3
und dann schauen wir an diesem Sonntag
traditionell auf das was uns kommende
Woche erwartet und wichtig wird der
heute journal Ausblick von Dominik
lestmeister
[Musik]
kommen nach den Kampfpanzer noch
Kampfflugzeuge wie geht es weiter mit
den Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine die
NATO Verteidigungsminister werden ab
Dienstag für zwei Tage in Brüssel über
die weitere militärische Unterstützung
der Ukraine beraten
wegen der hohen Flüchtlingszahlen sehen
sich Städte und Landkreise an der
Belastungsgrenze sie verlangen mir
Hilfen vom Bund am Donnerstag lädt
bundesinnenministerin Phaser deshalb zu
einem flüchtlingsgipfel nach Berlin ein
ebenfalls am Donnerstag werden die 73
Internationalen Filmfestspiele in Berlin
eröffnet der Krieg in der Ukraine ist
dabei ein zentrales Thema etwa 280 Filme
werden auf der diesjährigen Berlinale
gezeigt
am Freitag beginnt in München die
jährliche Sicherheitskonferenz drei Tage
lang diskutieren Politiker
Wissenschaftler und Militärs über
aktuelle Sicherheitsthemen erwartet wird
unter anderem us-vizepräsidentin Kamala
Harris
und jetzt noch der Ausblick auf das
Wetter in den kommenden Tagen morgen im
Westen und am Alpenrand länger sonnig
sonst nur zögernde Auflösung von Nebel
und Hochnebel in der Nordosthälfte sowie
in einigen Flusstälern auch ganz tägig
trübe fünf bis zwölf Grad in den
nächsten Tagen eine Mischung aus viel
Sonne einigen Wolken und zähmen Nebel am
Donnerstag im Nordwesten Regen
Höchstwerte 5 bis 12 Grad
und die Aussichten hier heißen Marietta
Slomka und Heinz Wolf nächste Woche
darauf dürfen sie sich freuen von uns
danke für Ihr Interesse und gegen 0 Uhr
gibt es dann die nächsten heute
Nachrichten mit Antoine vom gesamten
Team hier auch hinter den Kameras
[Musik]